Deadpool 2 is finally here and where
that comes more Easter eggs in an
industrial hatchery it's no surprise
that Wade Wilson would keep the
pop-culture references coming fast and
furious but Deadpool 2 also came with a
pretty wide assortment of Secrets
they'd have to dig pretty far and see a
comic archives to find gird your loins
and prepare yourself for spoilers like a
stolen Prison pen we're going deep ex
stuff that pulls connection to the x-men
movie universe isn't a secret it's just
the thing that the serious x-men films
don't really acknowledge there Paul
himself is a world's biggest critic of
Ryan Reynolds performance and x-men
origins Wolverine which he makes
explicitly obvious to during the movie's
mid-credits scene by pumping a dozen
bullets into the other original Deadpool
Deadpool - does everything it can to try
to weasel itself into the core x-men
movie world
Deadpool where's Professor Xavier
cerebro helmets and saves that it smells
are the original ex trilogies Professor
Patrick Stewart he also zips around the
x-mansion in the professor's iconic
wheelchair and most notably Deadpool
briefly stands in front of a room filled
with actual real-life x-men including
new Professor X James McAvoy it's the
stuff X fan dreams are made of
Essex stuff even though longtime x-men
foe mr. sinister aka Nathaniel Essex
hasn't actually appeared on the big
screen yet his presence and the X movie
universe looms large so far he's only
appeared in name by the end of x-men
apocalypse
his name is seen on a briefcase and
disconnected to the Weapon X facility
that created Wolverine Logan's
transition corporation which created
Laura aka X 23 has been confirmed to be
related to Essex Corp as well in
Deadpool - Essex is the name of the
school that tortures young mutants
including Russell out of using their
natural powers the pizarro x-mansion
seems to be pretty anti-mutant so while
their ideals don't really align with the
overall Essex ethos of mutant
experimentation the name remains a
common thread throughout all arms of the
X Universe Goonies never say die before
he was Santos or cable or anything else
for that matter Josh Brolin first
appeared on the big screen as brand
Walsh in the Goonies a fact that
Deadpool will not let him forget
Deadpool mockingly calling him one-eyed
Willy isn't just a digger his 1p /
one-eyed Willy was the pirate that the
Goonies were searching for in their own
like film one to double down on the goon
love after Deadpool is torn in two by
juggernaut and is recovering on the
couch he's wearing the exact same shirt
that chunk did in the Goonies it's salt
on out of love of course Ryan Reynolds
and Josh Brolin have a rack in ship both
starred in absolutely terrible DC movie
flops Green Lantern and Jonah Hex
respectively callback attack
Deadpool twos many commercials revealed
a whole family sized on this worth of
Easter eggs but a few super clever ones
were hidden in plain sight when an
exhausted Deadpool attempts to take out
a barrage of bullets with nothing but
his swords that's actually a cool back
to when he did the exact same thing with
much more unbelievable success in x-men
origins of Wolverine and yes the
Deadpool finding a whole lot of cocaine
and the cure for blindness stashed under
some floorboards in Al's apartment is an
unexpected cool back to the first
Deadpool film it's about 116 kilos of
cocaine buried somewhere in the
apartment right next to the cure for
blindness good luck
he wasn't kidding cameos city notably
absent from Deadpool twos many crazy
cameos was Marvel patriarch Stan Lee who
only appeared as a mural on the side of
a building and then poor two's teaser
trailer Wow nice suit Stan Lee
one might have also expected that poor
co-creator Rob Liefeld to appear again
after showing up in the first film but
he's nowhere to be seen buck
or - instead he's called out in a much
more creative way as a creator of Domino
who Deadpool proclaims who have a very
stupid serve powers and was probably
created by a guy who can't your feet
comic art historians will note that
mister Liefeld's grasp of the human
anatomy is creative at its best
hilarious at its worst and more often
the nuts includes large clouds of smoke
usually focused somewhere below each
character's knees we have a minute I
want to tighten those feet okay all
right noted Deadpool right sir Jerry
Duggan also gets a shout out the parkway
on which part of the epic convoy battle
sequence takes place is named after him
and yes your eyes were not deceiving you
that indeed was Brad Pitt's playing the
ill-fated Vanisher at one point
scheduled to play cable himself Pitt's
cameo appearance and the media death
were added in post-production
but and then the less pretty unexpected
also unexpected as a surprise appearance
of Alan Tudyk
a toilet-paper obsessed a good ol boy
appearing alongside Matt Damon buried
under so many prosthetics that he's
unrecognizable this of course as a
second Marvel cameo over the past year
ex farce the sudden gory departure of
almost the entirety of the newly formed
x-force is something of a surprise but
it really shouldn't be pretty much the
exact same thing happens in x-force
issue 116 when a newly formed group of
mutants calling themselves x-force are
immediately explosively dispatched
during their very first appearance among
them is site-geist the same tattooed as
her puking mutant that's welcomed into
Deadpool's x-force that's a two of one
one six on his arm wasn't just an
interstate it's the issue where he died
and we can't mention highly specific
numerical references without dev Paul's
prisoner number two for 601 now who's
the true for 601 most significantly it's
the number of Jean Valjean in lay
miserable a role played by Hugh Jackman
on the big screen bad taste
Deadpool co-star TJ Miller has been
embroiled in multiple controversies
since December of 2016 including but not
limited to calling in a fake bomb threat
on a train assaulting an uber driver
during a political arguments and
allegedly committing violence and sexual
assault against a woman in 2001 when the
latter accusations surfaced after
Miller's prominent role in
Paul too was already in production the
film's producers made the difficult and
controversial decision to keep the emoji
movie star in the picture but axiom from
Deadpool 3 still the film couldn't
resist taking a jab at the situation
during the news reports about fire fist
explosive meltdown the cruel at the
bottom of the screen mentions that
Christopher Plummer had turned down a
role in Deadpool 2 famously plumber we
shot all of Kevin Spacey scenes and all
the money in the world after Kevin
Spacey was accused of sexual misconduct
it's not like anything in Deadpool 2 was
in good taste anyhow good taste it's
hard to tell exactly where Deadpool ends
and Ryan Reynolds begins and it's a line
that's blurred constantly Deadpool signs
a Wolverine cereal box with Reynolds
name and later shoots Reynolds through
the head as he considers even thinking
about appearing in Green Lantern but
despite all of the movies leaps from
different realities and tasteless jokes
one throwaway line is more heart than
the whole film combined when Wade Wilson
considers the name Connor for his kid
it's not meaningless prior to the
original Deadpool coming out Ryan
Reynolds enjoyed a special screening of
the film with a make-a-wish kid named
Connor McGrath while Connor passed in
2016
Reynolds made sure that his love of
Deadpool and his legacy lived on in
tempo in the most heartwarming and
heartbreaking way possible costume
connection while Deadpool is mostly
known for his red and black duds he's
fought crime in a wide variety of colors
while seeking membership in the x-men
during Deadpool issue 16 he actually
makes his own x-men uniform with a giant
obvious X on the front whoever designed
the x-men's trainee uniforms in Deadpool
2 had a pretty much the same idea
Deadpool during his darker x-force days
has also been seen sporting a black and
gray version of his familiar costume his
charred costume near the end of the
movie is a dead ringer for his x-force
comics counterparts it's no coincidence
this is when the real x-force finally
comes together
sorry shatter star you suck o canada'
because you just can't have Ryan
Reynolds in the room without making a
few jokes about his home and native land
up north Deadpool 2 as a few quips about
America's friendly heart Canada much
more subtle however as a reference in
name only to Canada's number one
crime-fighting team that never mentioned
Alpha Flight in this case Alpha Flight
is little more than the name of an air
or travel agency posted as a taxi ad but
the sentiment is there and has covered
in maple syrup and hockey thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]